naturel régional en bresse l'idée lancée
en septembre dernier est loin de séduire
tout le monde
les avis sont partagés et la crainte de
subir une réglementation
environnementale encore plus lourde
subsistent non seulement on a besoin
d'explications on ne veut pas avoir de
nouvelles contraintes
on en a déjà beaucoup avec natura 2000
le biotope sur la commune de s'arrête on
a des puits de captage ce qui veut dire
que les agriculteurs ont encore dit il
contraindre les avis de l'eau en plus
moi ce qui me fait peur aussi s'est
ajoutée une strate
pourquoi créer un parc régional
si c'est pour englober des choses qui
existent déjà autrement
beaucoup de questions restent en suspens
pour certains élus pour d'autres malgré
les craintes
ce parc régional est l'atout qui manque
à la bresse pour attirer plus de
touristes des points de vigilance à
avoir les contraintes qui veulent
apporter la charte du parc naturel
régional est toujours utile en termes de
promotion des territoires ddt
valorisation de notre savoir faire
effectivement la ya des points positifs
apportés au niveau économique et
touristique
ça peut être une véritable plus value
pour le territoire le projet a subi un
premier revers avec le rejet de l'étude
de faisabilité par des membres du pays
de la bresse bourguignonne à l'origine
du projet la députée socialiste de la
bresse est prête à relancer l'idée c'est
pas un tacle de contrainte c'est un parc
de développement c'est ça qu'il faut
vraiment comprendre
on ne peut pas imaginer une telle
procédure lancée dans n'importe quel
territoire de la france c'est parce que
la bhr la bresse bourguignonne a une
richesse culturelle à une richesse
naturelle à des habitants à fort
potentiel qui ont su à la fois préserver
la culture et faire du développement
il faudra beaucoup de temps et
d'explication pour que cette idée
devienne réalité